Speaker 1: Let's dive into headfirst. The
Friday feedback, a.k.a. Friday feedback,
also known as really ignorant People write
to me and I struggle to explain the things
that they say. We're going to start today
with someone named Zoya. Ras Zuri. Zoya Ras
Xwoba. Who says you must be. Do lonely in your
dungeon. I know it's your job to talk bad about
Trump. Republican conservatives. That's how
you make views. But does it truly bring you
happiness? When was the last time you felt free,
peaceful and joyful? Go to church this Sunday,
seek and you will find the capital T truth.
Oh boy. It's hard to take this seriously
and engage with it in anything approximating a
serious matter. But it actually does bring me
happiness to be able to. And this is no disrespect
to anyone who likes it, but to be able to not have
some boss waiting for me who says, Sir, we start
at 905 and you didn't get here until 908 this
morning. And to be able to talk about or focus on
whatever I want any day, if I want to take time
off, I take time off like that. It really brings
me happiness to not only have that work schedule
and situation, but also to be able to have such
a great community. Present company, of course,
accepted it as far as this message is concerned of
people who I engage with, and it really does bring
me happiness. So I know that that's of course the
number one concern of Zo yara xwoba but no need
to worry about me. Thank you very much. D w says
Pacman, can you please explain why you never talk
about Bidens and Clinton's unclassified documents?
Because they're not classified? I'm guessing
that's an error. Only a president can declassified
documents, not a vice president or a secretary
of state. I wonder why most commenters on this
channel are only concerned about Trump's actions.
Could it be because they will let it slide if
they agree with the person's politics? No, no, no.
How many times have I talked about Biden's
documents and Hillary Clinton's documents
at this point? Dozens and dozens. The reality is
the facts are different. The way our correspondent
Luke Beasley explained to some of those Maga
MAGA donations MAGA battalions earlier this
week in Pickens, South Carolina, the facts
are different. Joe Biden had a small number
of documents. They were immediately returned when
found. There was no alleged obstruction. There was
no alleged witness tampering. There was no showing
the documents to random people on the portico of.
Speaker 2: Mar a Lago.
Speaker 1: Or whatever.
There was none of that. Hillary Clinton Yes,
she was careless. That was the determination.
But an investigation determined no crimes
were committed. I talk about it. It's just
that it's a different set of facts. What
this person really should be saying is,
I don't care that it's a different set of facts.
I want Biden and Hillary to be indicted, too, just
because of their partizan affiliation. I don't
want it to just be Trump. Well, maybe Trump's the
only one who committed crimes. Have to consider
that. Have to consider that next person who goes
by the username. Life is a gift. Cherish every
moment. All right. Says I was born in the United
States of America in 1950. For most of my life,
I thought of myself as a patriot. And I admired
and respected others who referred to themselves
as patriots. That all changed on January 6th,
2021. Now, I am very cautious around anyone who
calls themself a patriot. If this is patriotism,
I am very concerned for the future of the United
States of America. Well, of course they're
correct. And I've spoken about this before. The
right has obtained a monopoly on patriotism,
not on patriotism. The thing on patriotism, the
word and we've spoken before, but the difference
between patriotism and nationalism. We've done
that. We've gone down this rabbit hole before.
It is not. A uniquely right wing thing. And I
would argue there is nothing patriotic about the
modern MAGA movement. It is patriotic to say,
Hey, you know what? We're Americans. We're not
going to let anyone standard of living fall below
a certain level. It's patriotic to say, we'll make
sure everybody has housing and food and health
care while that's patriotism. That is just as
valid as whatever cockamamie version of patriotism
these people on the right ascribe to that word.
Stephen wrote in noticing what's been
happening on our tiktoks and says 500,000
on Tik Tok. But how many on troth troll Sancho?
Yeah. Listen, we're not we're not on troth
essential or truth social. But I have to tell you
what is happening on Tik tok is unbelievable. Now
I know Tik Tok may be banned and all these
different things. Listen, I get it, okay? I
have no control over that. To the extent that it's
a platform on which we can get our message out.
I think we're up to 530,000 followers on
TikTok, much of it because of the great
work of my colleague John in helping us build
that platform. Much of it because of the shift
to short form content. I know that this is really
difficult to believe. We now are seeing as many
monthly views on Tik Tok as we get on our YouTube
channel. And we've been on Tik Tok like a year
and a half and we've been on YouTube more than
a decade and the YouTube channel is big. It is
stunning the growth that we're having there. And
the important thing is we are getting the message
out at this point. I think I get recognized on the
street as much for, Hey, you're the Tik tok guy.
As as I do for YouTube. It's an incredible thing.
Colin Peter Koski says without Christianity,
you have chaos. Are you blind? You know,
whenever I see comments like these,
the same thought always occurs to me, which is,
are you telling me that the only thing keeping you
from acting in a disgusting or criminal way or
immoral way is your belief that Jewish carpenter
Jesus died and was resurrected and was born to a
virgin and there was this ark and eating shrimp
is bad. And like you're saying, if you didn't
have that, you'd be out murdering people. For
people to say we would have no moral compass if
we didn't have God telling us what to do. You're
saying the only thing keeping you from murdering
people is that God says it's not a good thing to
do. That's scary. That's really, really scary. And
so I struggle with this type of statement. Listen,
if the community and the idea of something bigger
than yourself from religion is a positive thing
for you and it helps you to connect with those
around you and have an optimistic outlook on life
all. But absolutely, there is no denying the
importance of religion separating, of course,
from specific religious beliefs. There's no
way that we can minimize some of the positive
things about religious community in history and
negative things as well we can talk about. But
without Christianity, you have chaos. Very,
very tough. Very, very tough. And by the way,
countries with very little Christianity often
have very little crime, which would be another
way to say they're not particularly chaotic.
Libby Shipman commented on Facebook and says,
The thing about Chris Christie is that no matter
how good he campaigns, it's obvious that he cannot
control his eating. So how can he be trusted to
control anything else? And Linda Anderson says
that is a ridiculous comment. Yeah, I mean,
listen, it's a pretty stupid thing to say.
He can't control his eating. So what, he he has
a worse. You'd rat you'd sooner give Trump the
nuclear codes because Chris Christie eats a
lot. I mean, it just it's it's it's quite a
strange non-sequitur. It really is. You know,
it's less about refuting the specifics of this,
but more about you're allowed to decide who to
vote for, using absolutely any rubric or standard.
And many of these people do. They're the message
we should get is that there are people like Libby
who would say, I guess I'd rather Trump because
Chris Christie is eats a lot. By the way,
Trump's also obese, which is a whole other
story. But maybe, maybe Libby prefers
I don't know who's thin Vivek Ramaswamy because
Vivek can control the amount he eats. And Chris
Christie get it? The this is what we're up against
and we are much better off just finding people and
getting them to vote rather than convincing people
like Libby to change their minds because they're
probably not going to a Reddit user. No fear of
stuff. Remember the David Pacman show subreddit?
Is that David Pacman Tor.com slash Reddit?
Knower of stuff says, Are we at a point where
conservatives are simultaneously buying and trying
to ban electric vehicles to own the Libs? Like,
wouldn't it be surprising if you had conservative
Elon Musk fanatics who bought Teslas partially
because they think it will trigger liberals by
supporting a musk company? But on the other hand,
you still have most conservatives who are anti
environmentalist and hate electric vehicles like
Marjorie Taylor GREENE, who columns that calls
them a threat to the country lawmaker in Wyoming
who pretty much tried to ban them basically to
own the libs. Yeah, it's it's it reminds me of the
vaccine. Donald Trump deserves all of the credit
for developing these vaccines which don't work,
are killing people. And I absolutely will not
take. Trump deserves credit for that. He's
way better than Joe Biden. What? Wait, so is the
vaccine good or bad? Doesn't matter. It is a very
similar thing with Twitter. It's easier because
it's like, okay, Twitter is less about lifestyle,
it's less about broader political belief.
It's like you're on Twitter or you're not.
You like you on Musk's handling of it or you
don't. The electric vehicle One is interesting
because a lot of these right wingers hate electric
vehicles, but at the same time, they do think that
it is an easy way now to trigger the left by
supporting Elon Musk. So maybe what they'll do
is they'll go and buy a Tesla to support Musk, but
then they'll burn it, I don't know, or something
like that. Like the people who are shooting
Bud Lights with with shotguns. It's all very,
very weird. All right. Lastly, Big D says to me on
Instagram, this guy is on the payroll of the left.
Don't believe him. He has. Not talked a word about
the Hunter Biden indictment. Thus guy is sketchy,
sketchy is misspelled. Well, Big D, a couple
different things. I've been talking about Hunter
Biden for years. I was away at a wedding the
week that Hunter struck a plea deal and I have
spoken about it since multiple times. So every
single one of these claims is false. By the way,
I'm on the payroll of the left. If by the payroll
of the left, you mean that there are people on the
left who get memberships on my website and support
my work? Guilty as charged. If you mean payroll of
the left, as in the Democratic establishment,
the DNC, George Soros or whoever are funding
this program, the answer is they are not. And
I challenge you to present a shred of evidence,
a shred of evidence for a decade. These folks have
been saying that you must be on the payroll of the
DNC, not even a Democrat. Why would they pay
me? It doesn't make a lot of sense. MSNBC must
be paying you. Why would MSNBC pay people who
aren't even on their network? Very strange. Not
much of an understanding of how. Anything works.
Quite frankly. Find some kind of proof that any of
these organizations are paying me. And I will say,
You got me, you got me. I did everything right,
and they indicted me. Okay. I will say it here.
All right. We have a fantastic bonus show for you.
Sign up at join PACOM, folks. In all seriousness.
The Children's Critical Thinking book is available
for preorder on Kindle and in paperback. Right
now, I hold in front of me proof number one print.
This is the first proof. This is an historic
item. Go to David Packman dot com slash book.
Donate them to your kids class. Bring them
around to school libraries, give them as gifts.
This is really something special that we're
doing. David Pacman, dotcom slash book. We'll
see you on the bonus show. If you're not on the
bonus show, then I'll see you back here Monday.